the Joe Rogan experience those movies
that are really big you also have to
think of how much money's invested in
them right and huge and if they go bad
it's a giant financial is it like and go
bad means like not make a billion
dollars
yeah well or lose money like dr.
Dolittle right right yeah I think that
month that movie is probably gonna lose
money oh really
well just real dangerous coming from a
guy like Robert Downey jr. who's amazing
yeah who's so incredible in the Avengers
and that movie made [ __ ] kajillions of
dollars yeah all those movies are
amazing and then he goes and does his
kids movie and it really doesn't do well
it was dangerous those movies are like
oh Jesus Ron thin ice yeah back to the
shore no dangerous for who for the actor
yeah for the for the production company
for everybody you know what if they come
to you know the production company a
year later and say hey we have a new
idea for a movie in the productor or the
studio and the studio is like hey [ __ ]
you we lost a hundred million dollars on
you you [ __ ] thank you see all the
issues with cats oh yes that was
probably the biggest financial disaster
here right there pulled it back to like
redo it and they're gonna release it yes
how many people are making fun of it
they do it again they like yeah they
left the visual effects team only
apparently like nine months now they
left watches on people it didn't cover
their hands up all sorts of bad stuff I
saw it with my kids we booked my
daughters like we have to sleep good
though like we want to watch as a
disaster no because in the beginning
like we thought my daughters like we
have to see the worst movie of the
decade how we not go see that it was
really brutal and it first that is it's
bad it's so bad is it good no it's so
bad that's not good bad yeah it's just
bad like so bad it's not good no like in
the beginning you have a laugh and it's
like alright I can see why this is gonna
suck and then by the end of two hours
you're like no I've just been hit in the
head with a shovel Sapa yeah it's really
bad and you're seeing all these people
that have been in other things who are
just not talking about you know like
Jane Judi Dench and it's ray it's bad
there's some other movie that came out
recently that someone was saying was as
bad as the room oh really that movie the
room see if you find that movie and it
was really yeah there was a whole
article about it saying that this this
movie is so bad that it's good that you
need to I didn't even finish typing and
it kept in it auto-completed what is it
well it says now he's showing off his
skills no it said that it finished up
says the room is the worst movie ever
yeah a movie as bad as the room what
shocked the one that shocked me that
everyone was said was so bad was Will
Ferrell and john c reilly
in that one the new one right the was
it's a canadian movie so bad it rivals
the room yeah what is that
that's called ryan's babe I don't know
never heard of it is that a recent
article yes from four days ago yeah
that's right yeah the people were
telling me you have to see it from 2000
it was that movie movie but someone just
discovered you put Will Ferrell and john
c reilly doing anything and i'm i'm in
right and he will really rebelled
against it that girl's hot though this
looks pretty just in her underwear
running around for some reason perfect
this is it's pretty gonna redo cats
already did I think they reacted it and
then but if they rieta tit everyone's
gonna know that sucked so bad they
re-edit it I've never heard of that ever
it's released no like you [ __ ] no like
okay we'll fix it want me back how much
money is cats lost didn't put it out
they were they'd like put out a trailer
and internet freaked out they're like oh
okay well we'll redo it yeah it's been a
bunch of money redoing it Sonic the
Hedgehog yeah really I got now it
actually looks a little bit better yeah
they gave him like better teeth or
something dude it's hard man making the
movies got to be the most brutal thing
ever he's so hot guys in here that have
poured their heart and soul into a movie
for years like motherless Brooklyn I in
moving I know that in here it was it
good I don't know and I love him and I
love the subject matter he loved that
movie and he put such heart and soul
into the soundtrack no and I haven't
seen it yeah you know sometimes Jesus
Christ cats headed for a hundred million
dollar box-office loss uh what the
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god oh my god I just
keep thinking about them all like being
at craft services and backstage like
this is pretty great huh let me see that
gallery sticks
[Applause]